now thank you so much for joining us  here at noon i'm heather mills we start  with the ongoing search by both the fbi  and metro police for two people wanted  in a deadly robbery right now they're  looking for michael overton and  christine schultz  this robbery happened on the 25th metro  says three people entered a home armed  with the intent to rob the residents a  20-year-old woman in the home was killed  after a gunfire exchange one of the  suspects kamari oliver he got away  initially but was arrested a few days  later  this murder is a result of a very brazen  residential robbery  we determined that christina schultz had  set up the robbery  fbi and metro announcing a 20 thousand  dollar reward to find overton and  schultz  this is a developing story you can stay  with eight news now for more information  as it comes in